larae is one of the biggest creators in
the world
rae i am so excited to just spend a few
minutes talking to you human to human
because you know if you have a lot of
people
who are of a younger age watching you
what would you truly want them to know
well i do have a young audience and i do
try to
put out the message of as like
this is going to be cry too be who you
are at the end of the day no matter what
goes on in your life no matter who
judges you it could be your parents your
best friend
teacher you shouldn't let anyone's
opinion change the way you want to live
your life because
at the end of the day you only get one
life
literally but letting people
change the way i feel about certain
situations or change how i feel about
things because
they don't approve of it it really
messed me up mentally and growing up i
was scared this goes for anybody whether
if you're in the lgbt community or just
a
straight girl trying to figure out her
way
your parents are gonna always have
something to say and you don't have to
live by what your parents
beliefs are how did you figure that out
for yourself it took a lot it really did
um
still working on it obviously the one
star was realizing my worth and the
scoringest way possible but it's not
easy for other people because like i can
just see her and be like hey guys know
your worth but it's so much harder than
it's you know being sad and how could
you bring someone who lived a different
life or has a different mindset into
your upbringing your world the way that
you and your friends found each other
and play together um there's a lot of
parents who have kids who follow me
and there's been times where my um some
of my fans they tell me that they're
scared to tell their parents who they're
watching on youtube because they've
heard their parents say homophobic
comments or even racial comments the
first step is always accepting accept
your child for anything they do it's
illegal though
that's when we got to put your foot down
but if it's willing to love who they
want to love or be who they want to be i
don't think any parent should stop their
child from doing that what do you wish
for
younger people growing up and their
future when you look around the world
the planet humanity
very big subjects right
what do you want to see
as we
get from one year to the next
oh so much i think i would love to see
the end of just overall like crime on
black trans lives that's one that's very
it's very i don't want to curse here i
was going to say a word don't worry
we'll beep it out it's very it's
it's
um it's not really getting better i feel
as though people really don't take
initiative to take the time to actually
know that's an actual problem even black
lives in general that is a very big
issue that i feel as though no one they
talk about it so much but it seems like
people just forget it that easily until
the next crisis happens
and when we look to history we keep
repeating ourselves yeah well i think
that what you are doing
[Music]
at the end of the day is advancing us i
think you are taking younger people and
all people by the hand and
showing them the way and then i guess my
last question to you larae is what makes
you happy what makes you laugh i feel
like you right now you're making me very
happy good i'd love to move i would say
for sure just spending time with my
friends but i actually only have like
three close friends that i that would
literally make me laugh and i'll hang
out with them all the time
and
that's what makes me happy just having
those three people in my circle and just
living my best life even oprah winfrey
is coming out and saying she has three
friends and that's all you need so
you're in keeping with oprah which is
great news
right i mean come on over to that that
means to me a new hashtag or something
immediately i just created something i
think you did another i'll give it to
you copywriting and by the way i brought
you something this is the very first one
um so i'm so excited to give it to you
thank you it's our new is this what i
think it is what is this mascara yeah
oh i love you you're literally the very
first person i'm giving this to way i
feel special let's be super
la i have to find out your son what's
your sign i'm a pisces oh
true pisces you're so perfect
what are you cancer emotional well we're
water we're still water we're so
emotional
and incredibly intuitive
we see each other we really do
and i'm very honored to make your
acquaintance i love what you do let this
be the beginning of a beautiful
friendship thank you i think it is too
i can't wait to do that i can't wait to
see i'm sending you pictures you're the
very first person i could take i know i
feel so cool